go uh all right we are live let me just
check if everything is working properly
uh YouTube says we have excellent
connection uh just let me check if the
audio is Here video is here and uh with
me uh for this uh spectacular event the
multivers X Christmas chess Arena I have
the chief accelerator of Multiverse X
Benjamin minku is it MSU or minku minku
ah minku yeah uh so thank you for
joining me uh I actually did not think
that I would be able to get you because
you're such a busy guy you know you're
always working and you're like uh you
know fully operational 22 hours a day uh
so thanks a lot for for joining in and
it's a wonderful opportunity to uh you
know tell people more about Multiverse
sex I've been following the project for
some I would say 5 years uh I even uh I
I don't know if I've ever told you how I
Came Upon uh Multiverse X or or as it
was called U it wasn't even e it was ER
at the time exactly exactly no Antonio
it's a great pleasure to be here and um
have this conversation and uh
participate in the in the competition we
sort of always do it very short term
probably next year um if we continue
we'll announce it a bit um
sooner to be here exciting and I'm
actually quite curious how you found out
about El at that point and Multiverse X
now well to to to be very brief about it
uh I uh started getting requests from
people if they could make a donation in
crypto on the channel and I had no idea
about crypto I I had I had no idea about
anything and I got myself a book or
maybe even two books like crypto for
dummies and then I read it and U there
were like maybe eight criteria uh each
company had to meet in order for it to
be a proper product and then I scanned
which like which project has those eight
and I came up upon El and it was a
fairly early in the project I think it
was like 20 2016
2017 uh I think the price of it was like
maybe
$3 uh maybe five I don't know and it's
sort of met all the criteria that's why
I started following the the project I
even followed you on on on Twitter and
that's basically how I got into it uh I
got to know you you know through through
Twitter and you guys seem like uh you
know a wonderful crew and you you really
seem to be doing good work and you're
constantly working like you have a you
literally have a weekly update every
week uh yeah so uh always curious to um
discover or hear the stories how how
people discover um at that point lron
then now Multiverse X I think it was
probably
2018 more yeah uh something like that or
or even 2019 because to end of 2017 we
actually unveiled uh let's say part part
of the product we were um discussing on
on the breakthroughs and and so forth
and um you you're essentially mentioning
a few key things which I think if
someone is from the outside and hears
about blockchain they're probably
wondering what what is this now of
course five years later after we started
people I'm sure have heard about crypto
they started using it and and all of
that but the brief version of the idea
is as I was mentioning before um it's
sort of like if you think about
Teal's um Teal's quote or the deals
saying where you you sort of have um we
wanted flying cars and all we got were
140 characters um you can apply this
same idea to to the financial system we
sort of wanted internet across all types
of let's say communication and for the
financial system despite us having the
internet for now um 30 years fully
incorporating all the other fields um of
Technology uh for whatever reason the
financial system has stubbornly been
left
behind and um I think blockchain is just
this new type of computer um that
provides cryptographic guarantees um
provable transparency deterministic
computation on top of which you can
build a new Financial system you can
just build something that is truly
accessible to anyone in the world um
that enables some new type of Primitives
that can work 24/7 that are automatic
which which actually brings us to a very
interesting point which is we now have
really Advanced artificial intelligence
and I I would venture to say that maybe
by end of 2024 will'll each have agents
of our own that start working for us
doing different type of work for us of
course AI assistants exists and you can
use them but I I would say the next 6 to
12 months will probably enable this new
type of artificial intelligence agents
where um ideally one person has an army
of them and some of them can get stuff
done in let's say soft in the software
space some of them can get stuff done in
the creative space and and so forth and
the key part that blockchain ties into
this uh through to which the blockchain
ties into this is blockchain the
blockchain is a type of computation that
is complementary to this type of Agents
with um artificial intelligence where
your agent will probably have a native
crypto wallet under which it will
receive transactions it will initiate
transactions and and so forth so I think
that type of future we can discuss about
Futures in five or 10 years which can be
a lot more f fascinating and interesting
but I believe that even what we'll have
during the next one or two years will be
a bit mindblowing compared to what we
have right
now this is just a bit of a let's say
initial conversation starter I'm curious
maybe how you see that if if you see
something that um is extremely
interesting even for for um the
different parts of um of the world that
maybe don't have as advant on financial
infrastructure as maybe the US has no in
my opinion it's the it's exactly the the
speed of the transaction and that you
can uh use the transaction where
whenever you want like you don't have to
like you want to do something at 600
p.m. on Friday uh but the banks are
closed you don't have to wait for Monday
so just putting it uh putting it to the
most basic uh use uh but I also have a
sort of a compliment for you I have a
friend here in in Croatia he has a not
not a crypto company he's a he's a s
sort of a software engineer and they uh
build only on bitcoin and I asked him
have you ever heard of elund or
Multiverse sex uh he said I haven't as
uh he only ever did Bitcoin but he said
that he will investigate it for me and
he said that what he found was he was
extremely
impressed thank you especially about the
about the I don't know how do you call
it like the uh that that it's sharded
like that it's uh sort of maybe not
infinitely scalable but it is uh fairly
scalable yes indeed I I do believe that
let's say if we boil it down the idea of
having a kind of in infrastructure that
just works like the internet for the
financial system where you can make
transactions anywhere in the world in an
instant with a trivial cost that should
be the world we live in um and yet it's
not quite there yet so I think with
blockchains we will have this um and
have this right now now the question as
with the Internet is twofold one um do
we have an infrastructure that can scale
like the internet you remember the
internet in its early days with the dial
up uh speeds it was pretty slow pretty I
can still hear it
dialing yes the the modems kicking in
and all of that but then the transition
from dialab to broadband changed the
perception changed the Paradigm
completely and I think that the second
part is um having a kind of ux that
enables this type of interaction with
the technology just the just as the
browser did for the internet is crucial
to open up the technology open up the
access to simple people that want to
just make the transactions use them and
so forths and what we've built at
Multiverse X indeed is um a kind of set
of breakthroughs the first one is this
architecture that is State sharded it
means that you can split and parallelize
transaction processing to scale
throughput in a way that is sublinear
but um it essentially enables the kind
of scaling that you have on the internet
and then um the the transactions are
very inexpensive you can also build
applications on top of this and so forth
so it definitely enables that type of
future today but I also think it goes
beyond this where um of course people
once they start
using new tooling like AI tooling um I
do believe that most of the transactions
will in interestingly enough machine to
machine transactions and being able to
have a kind of wallet and an agent as
funny as it sounds now um I I believe
this will be the way that a lot of
people will make money nothing five or
10 years but during the next um let's
say one year two years and uh we're
we're super excited about this as you've
mentioned we're
we're a team um that from the start we
built around the smartest people um
we've we've known um together with my
brother sort of I always repeat this
idea because it compresses the essence U
we've built a team with which we can
literally build rockets and so um then
we could solve with a team like that we
can solve any problem that we encounter
just give a
a bit of time and good energy there is
no obstacle will uh will not um pass and
find a solution
too yeah and as I understand it the the
multiex blockchain so far has had zero
down time
100% Z zero down time and I think there
are a lot of let's say detailed or very
interesting ideas that we've put in
Beyond this initial breakthrough so
having zero downtime is one thing um
another of the let's say perhaps one of
the largest problems that people um have
is this idea of hacking a kind of
scamming um version that happened
fishing version scamming um attacks that
happened in the crypto space and with
exportal which is this very simple and
cool um super app um Financial super app
we've built this idea of a onchain tofa
a kind of two- Factor authentication and
guardian within your app which just um
enables a different level of security it
means that whenever even if someone
steals your wallet they cannot get the
second part of the two Factor
authentication in order to steal your
funds so all of a sudden you not only
have a way of um using the technology
but then protecting the user users
making sure that they're still alive the
second day that's um that's also
extremely extremely
important also one thing that I'm
interested in are you are you looking at
some point maybe in the future to make X
portal like sort of the the one app that
can be used uh for everything like for
for finances for socializing
for 100% this is the idea so um X portal
is now this um super app that we believe
will will be will work as a kind of
crypto wallet first serving um many
blockchains the most advanced ones the
most interesting ones so it is already
multi-chain it is already multiwallet
but you'll also have Fiat and um here
Multiverse X differentiate itself
because X portal already has a card
through which you can use your crypto
the crypto you have in your wallet let's
say you have some eold which is the
native currency of Multiverse X um you
can already use the exportal super app
um order a card and then with this
internet money go outside buy some
groceries and use it in the real world
which is extraordinary but then it goes
even beyond that um you already have a
kind of app store within the app you
already have chat you already have a lot
of cool features that can be
used not only by crypto native people
but then also by um a lot of people that
just want to use this type of technology
for um for for their daily lives yeah I
was uh I was able to get it in the first
wave I've been using it for like a month
and a half now and yeah I mean works
works very nice looks very nice so yeah
definitely fully
operational yeah thank you great great
to hear the feedback and always curious
to actually hear feedback from the
community as people play with the app
discover new things we're always looking
to um to improve stuff we were just
discussing with the team today there's a
really cool feature of a kind of
exportal gift card where you essentially
through a link incorporate money and
then enable this enables when you meet
with your friends um and so forth even
for Christmas enables a very simple way
of sending for instance one eold um
where they just open the link um install
the app and claim that eold in their
wallet which is um a lot simpler than
explaining what it does what it is and
and all of that yeah what is the sort of
uh What uh with everything that's been
happening in the crypto world like with
the with the FDX and with everything uh
what's uh the simplest way to explain to
people that like the the like this is a
different in what environment what makes
it different in its
Essence I mean the the key Point here is
this you always will have the cycles of
new technologies coming in um taking
time to install the technology um people
getting excited but doing a lot of
experiments but it usually takes a few
years until the technology is ready and
then finally penetrates uh the the
society what we're doing um and I think
a lot of people in the in the space are
doing right now is we're taking a very
different approach we're we're building
these very important Bridges with for
instance the most important Regulators
central banks Ministers of several
countries then build Bridges with some
of the Top com technology companies in
the world um like Google Amazon Deutsche
Telecom tensent and so forth which all
um have announced some collaborations
with Multiverse X already then we're
building a lot of applications we in
fact have thousands of Builders from
around the world that build on this open
source technology that is um open for
anyone to take to tweak to improve and
and all of that and then lastly we're
also building a set of applications um
that enable even faster iterations so
whereas there are thousands of apps
already in the ecosystem for people to
use with defy with nfts and so forth um
the fact that you have something like
exportal just accelerates the iteration
exploration process and you already see
an application that uses this technology
in real life um from the start to the
point where you can buy your groceries
so I think the the point where the
entire industry is right now um is very
exciting both macro and micro and um I I
very much look forward to the idea of
onboarding the next billion users
because while everything is still
exciting we're we've just started um
this is still super early and um
everything we're building is to on board
the next billion
users yeah I think that's uh that's the
most that we can expect from uh fairly a
short
intro before the tournament starts so
thank you for that and yeah if you if
you'll ever feel like it I would very
much enjoy having like a even an hourong
conversation about everything as I'm
sure people uh people would love to hear
from someone who's really behind the
project uh
firsthand definitely uh would love um
I'm I'm very curious how the competition
will will go May May the best um player
win and um keep up the great work thanks
a lot we'll do likewise keep building
thank you until next time happy holidays
cheers
likewise all right so uh that was a
short discussion uh with uh with benam
minku uh from Multiverse x uh who are
who are uh kind enough to sponsor this
uh wonderful event so many people here
and uh yeah it's a fairly strong one
here the first game we are checking is
between chess master 2006 and Contra
yako I think Contra yako is the top seed
of the tournament from uh from Mexico at
uh no he's the second seed yeah chess
master 2006 is the top seed I think at
least for this game but we'll see and
yeah uh hello everyone in the in the
chat I've uh I've greeted you all uh
before but yeah uh doing so again and
yeah hope most of you can enjoy the
event hope most of you will play a few
games maybe even you know be the strong
player and yeah let's check it out if
you guys have any questions uh I'm also
reading the chat now so yeah let's
uh uh let's uh get this going uh sorry
about that let me just fix this a little
bit yeah there we go all
right that was a bit in the
way and Bruno Bruno pavich hello haven't
seen you in a while but that's also
because I haven't streamed in a while I
usually stream like U uh every every six
months uh all right so what do we have
here
uh black pushing for the win with an
extra Pawn but uh yeah it's not going to
be easy uh this could be this could be
uh one of the worst positions you could
have in a tournament like this because
you have to win games but you have to
win them quickly because a lot of people
are playing and this uh with with a 1
second increment could really last for
for like a couple couple of minutes and
you're wasting precious time on uh sort
of trying to push one game for a win uh
yeah so it's very interesting and maybe
even because it's the first game you
don't really lose your streak or
anything so I don't know I don't know if
uh if it's a good idea to waste this
much
time uh juara any famous players yeah
there are many famous players
uh I think our top page is strictly
Grand
Masters
where is your friend young which friend
young and okay oh he runs into Checkmate
very nice with 13 seconds on the clock
nicely
done all right okay we have uh FID
Master super power already already three
victories and going into his fourth
one xjm
greetings thank you dm1 I am uh I'm
always trying to do better yeah fedia
Master superpower uh who only ID only
created his uh yeah he only created I
think his uh handle for this tournament
uh but yeah he's crushing
everyone he's crushing everyone all
right who do we have maybe someone who
just started Captain Grandmaster Captain
Jack Sparrow all right let's see
it uh who is Captain Jack Sparrow again
let me just check quick
yeah he's
a a mysterious
person greetings from
Athens yeah and berserking is allowed
although so far I haven't seen anyone
berserk aventurat how much is 400 eold I
I'm not sure what the exact price is now
but it's around
$25,000 I enjoying the Rapid Videos yeah
I enjoy making them uh not having all
that much success now that I've uh
gotten to like maybe close to 2300 but I
am doing I am doing okay and yeah it's a
king hunt and it will be a Checkmate
very nicely done by Grandmaster Captain
Jack Sparrow
all right let's go who takes the lead in
the tournament yeah he lost the first
game uh all right let's uh okay let's
check out one more from Captain jck
Sparrow yeah Panda that is true uh
because if you berserk you you lose the
the plus one then it's just 30
seconds so limbo yeah likewise hope have
a good
one Antarctic B uh sorry I haven't seen
you asking
anything you're not asking anything
you're just uh trolling if you if you'll
ask a question yeah oh you said po yeah
POS Antarctic
B I will keep up with the rapid
action I most certainly will not just
for the content the content isn't all
that impressive but I actually enjoy
playing
it
and that's it Captain Jack Sparrow loses
the international Master Joseph from
Earth very nicely
done all right okay so it's still fairly
early on in the tournament but we do
have super power super power FID Master
uh on a streak five straight
wins Ireland's greatest
champion what is brazer Bing a
berserking is uh you give up half of
your time and you also lose increment
but if you win you get an extra
point Thank you Mr Antarctic b or or
Miss I I enjoy making them how is my pet
dog me is M me is actually fine he's
just uh too old to go up the stairs uh
I'm pretty sure he could if he wanted to
he just he just doesn't want
to yeah yeah but he's fine he's
downstairs you know just
chilling all right so we have a peace
sacrifice for the
attack and it seems like black has quite
a lot to defend with here so we'll
see yeah with so little time on the
clock I would I would lose this in an
instant any strong Grand Masters playing
I I'm pretty sure there are many strong
Grand Masters
playing uh I don't know if any any from
the like top 10 are playing as they also
have to have to travel uh to you know to
to participate in the world rapid and
Blitz Championship I don't know how long
it takes them to to get there uh but it
does start in some three days so maybe
they like to uh come a bit early you
know uh get rid of the jet lag so uh a
lot of people might even be
traveling all right so we'll see what is
this some nasty discoveries being
threatened
here uh yeah there's no Queen F3 since
the queen defends are there any super
nasty discoveries here that's the
question okay so he finds one but is it
nasty enough yeah it is it is nasty
enough
wow and he takes him down that's a first
loss for superpow uh evil hamburger
takes the win very nicely
done all right who's still undefeated
let's check if anyone's still undefeated
yeah International Master Joseph but
okay uh he's uh about the end the game
and yeah he wins another one so seven
games in a row or I think first one was
a draw but that's still
undefeated Brown Bailey thank you man
thank you for the kind
words
V Antonio thank you thank
you who is ala
playing someone said ala is
playing how's Yan doing Yan is always
doing great Yan is always doing great
but he's always busy you know I would I
would ask him to join for a nice stream
but uh yeah maybe maybe I ask him for
for the next
one
ah he's playing okay guca yeah ala
number seven now all right we'll check
up on on ala after this
game he's not uh as I understand that he
will not be playing in the world rapid
and Blitz Championship so he decided to
exact his wrath on everyone in this
one
uh okay Antarctic B send me an email uh
about what what what it is that you you
guys are doing and I will check it
out sad yeah like I said me me is doing
okay yeah and the link for the
tournament is in the description you
guys are definitely welcome to join in
and uh you know still a few points from
alza Majestic 12 thanks a lot man I do I
do try and love what I
do champion of the people yeah thank you
Shady
gamer you would like to learn some
creation words those are those are
extremely
difficult but I don't mind sharing some
with you
all right so Joseph really really
playing much much faster here or maybe
it's
ysf uh no I'm not playing I I'm just
showcasing games there are too many good
strong players here for you guys to be
watching my
games if it's not possible to join that
means you haven't played at least 50
games you have to play at least 50 games
uh that's something I mentioned before
every tournament uh if I allow just
anyone to join then you know people will
create accounts and just cheat this way
at least you have to play 50 games and
then if you still want to cheat okay I
mean do your thing but at least you you
had uh to work for your
meal all right where is where is ala oh
he's here oh he just
lost ala versus evil hamburger let's see
it yeah who beat
ala we'll
see
yeah he goes for the he went for the
early Queen trade and now he just wants
to outplay his opponent uh and be much
faster
yeah uh yes there is a prize for this
tournament sponsored by Multiverse X
they they they are sponsoring the
tournament with 400
eold uh that's uh at the last time I
checked before the tournament it was
around some
$25,000 yeah 1 plus one is tricky I was
uh I considered making it a OnePlus zero
I know some people really prefer a
OnePlus Zer but then you it's a
completely different chess like it's
then it's a flagging event and with one
plus one it's still uh well yeah
like stronger player wins with one plus
one with 1 plus Z I think uh you know it
it uh generally f the the flagger but
one plus one will still give us uh you
know very good games so I don't know you
could go both ways I I could also make a
one plus zero one if you guys want to
see
that yeah awful I'm not I wouldn't say
I'm uh I'm passionate about crypto but I
I do uh I do like to learn and yeah I've
been I've been checking up on what
Benjamin and his team have been doing
for for for like five or six years now
and uh you know there are others of
course who are doing great work but uh
uh I I started following them fairly
early on and uh yeah they seem to be
really nice
people what's the best place in Croatia
according to you well it's hard to say I
mean best place for
what like uh for a vacation def
definitely the
seaside
all right ala definitely better here on
time what oh yeah he missed that but uh
are the pawns winning yeah they are yeah
they
are yeah ala will Queen first but no
evil hamburger does not want to waste
time uh he knows ala is capable of
winning this all right uh alza even with
the win he dro DRS out from the top 10
yeah everyone's killing it in this one
Hansen on Twitch
also also without a
loss I actually have no idea who that is
Hansen Hansen
twitch it's not Eric
Hansen but no this is not Hansen this is
Hansen
positive show adventures TV in
Albania yeah uh like I said send send me
an email uh regarding what it is yeah
I'll definitely look into
it any books I recommend for players
like you current rating is 1,200
extremely passionate about Chess but uh
would love to get better uh anything by
like I would say like anything by Jeremy
Silman you will you know you will
improve like a thousand points if you if
you go through some of his books uh
uh but uh yeah I mean you you could also
go for for pretty much anything if
you're if you're at that rating it's uh
mostly about uh you know some general
knowledge and studying the end
game just don't don't start by starting
openings that's not uh that's not where
you want to
go all right uh Hansen twitch takes this
one and now he is uh yeah one of the few
unbeaten ones but yeah uh M B2 from
Germany also still without a loss uh I'm
pretty sure I knew who that
was pretty sure I knew who that was yeah
but no everyone's uh everyone's uh
playing in
Kongo yeah he's on
fire uh and I'm pretty sure I knew who
it was yeah but rated 3,6 from Germany
could be could be anyone yeah yeah could
be blue bom could be blue bom I think uh
it's definitely not
Vincent I'm guessing Vincent would be
higher rated If he if he was serious
about
playing oh yeah someone says MSB too is
blue
bomb oh yeah MSB yeah Matias blue bomb
yeah it does Mak
sense no I don't think it's Gustafson
imagine the match between fiser and
tonov at Christmas yeah it would be that
definitely would be a wonderful present
and also a Christmas miracle since they
are you know no longer with
us uh yeah MSB really destroying
everyone here so let's just check out a
few
more
Damian kmit also greetings and blessings
thank you for joining in and uh yeah
enjoy some nice uh some nice
chess uh you know people people have to
decide here do they want to play good
chess or do they want to flag and
win yeah where is Magnus to get his 15K
Christmas present uh I don't think
Magnus uh I don't think like for for a
tournament that's not organized by by
like a big organizer aside from that I
don't think Magnus ever accepted prize
money like it was even uh I think he won
like the first eight I'm going to say
eight or could be less could be more uh
first eight like Lees titled Arenas and
he always gave the money back boosting
the price fund until that one tournament
I think where he played uh from a van or
maybe I've mixed two events together and
then I think maybe like penguin got
first place
and then shattered the price fund and
then it it started from a th000
again but maybe I've said a lot maybe
not eight but definitely like four or
five is Magnus going to play in the
world rapid and Blitz I don't see why
not I mean that's uh I mean for everyone
I'm pretty sure that's the most fun they
can have in
chess
yeah uh what do I think about the future
of chess with engines evolved that much
that it's a sort of a memory struggle to
remember lines rather than over theboard
thinking yeah I think uh of course those
who rely uh solely on those engine lines
will not do very well because uh against
a strong opponent uh you know you will
reach a position I could be could be 30
well maybe even 35 you know moves deep
and you will have a an ironclad position
that's been evaluated by the engineer to
depth 100 and says no this is a draw uh
but you know you still have to prove it
and play if your opponent wants to
torture you he will play 100 more moves
so you have to you have to know how to
play chess doesn't matter if you can uh
equalize you know by by opening
knowledge and uh I mean Magness has
proven that time and time again it
doesn't matter if you if you get
uh uh a a uh drawn position like 30
moves in he will he will force you to
play 100 moves If he if he wishes
to why is hiar not playing the world
rapid and Blitz I have no idea probably
he decided it was better to stream it
but I don't know for a fact that he's
not playing it would be it would be a
surprise for me if uh he wasn't actually
playing
no i' I've haven't had all that much far
in a fun in a bar lately uh mostly
hitting the library these
days miton Raj hey my old
adversary from
liees uh you know doing great always
doing great hope you are as
well and uh yeah again a position where
players have to okay a draw offered will
a draw be accepted but that's a lot of
seconds for not accepting a
draw he will try to flag him with half
the time
interesting oh he uh he him being Hikaru
has criticized it for being so far away
and the during Christmas yeah it's uh
it's always a day after
Christmas but yeah I mean he he is
married now and I guess he you know
wants to spend time with family and he's
already qualified for the candidate so
you know might as well just stream
it all right Matias blam still
undefeated yeah going very
strong am I proud such great players
like ala are participating in my event
uh I could not be more proud yeah I mean
I'm uh they're not of course uh such
strong players will join if there's a if
there's a price fund so it's uh mostly
multivers sex that enabled this by by
allowing us to have such a such a
wonderful price fund I mean $25,000 is
uh really a lot of money for a 2-hour
event uh uh so yeah I mean it's really
uh really great from them and we haven't
like planned this in advance like a
month or two months in advance uh we
basically I I uh contacted them maybe a
week ago and we got everything together
like maybe over the course of the past
two days so yeah it was a it was a very
nice gesture like I said especially now
that you know it's not like it's a bull
market and it's not like you know the
the prices are going haywire uh it's
been pretty calm for the past few years
and they they're still very much willing
to sponsor a chess event so I think
that's really
cool yeah MSB really really tightening
the screws
here you're very welcome Mr Joker I I
Tred to get as many people into chess
yeah D5 Falls and that will be
it oh that's a nice
Fork oh that's a nice counter move also
yeah he had to capture that otherwise
some nasty discoveries would be in order
H but yeah he's just up too much
material and up too much time yeah very
nicely done yeah it's hard you beat the
2600 player you gain only one rating
Point okay who do we
have anyone else
undefeated nope everyone has at least
one loss except
MSB nope okay here we have Kera whoever
that
is uh undefeated from
Georgia simply garbage we have about the
same rating in bullet now all right I'm
guessing we should definitely play a few
games yeah MSB just throwing the kitchen
sink at
everyone you want some random lower
rated games of your actual fans yeah we
could also do that uh but we don't uh we
don't have GMS playing on my channel
every day so I'm pretty pretty sure
people would would would watch that
uh but yeah we we we could definitely
check out some of the games it is a
two-hour event so we do have
time hey Alex from Bucharest greetings
man yeah I I I I actually expected a lot
more people to join the the tournament
uh but with uh uh with with such strong
players I think they just uh decided
that it's better to
watch you should obviously host a four
player chess bullet Christmas event why
a four player bullet event you Oh you
mean like four for really strong players
and then a a bullet Arena between
them yeah my player paranoid
hippie all right let's uh I can just do
it this way I don't have have to do it
that way all right so uh Matias still
undefeated however he lost his streak
yeah he got a draw uh all right let's
see mut Pro from
Vietnam also undefeated for the moment
and he has also defeated me I played a
game against him I have no idea when but
yeah he defeated me as well which is uh
you know which is not weird at
all thanks for covering the chess drama
lately I haven't uh I I don't remember
actually covering any drama I merely
covered the you know the events of the
world as they
unfolded my videos are perfect to fall
asleep too yeah I get that a
lot uh probably maybe because I don't
yell yeah me Le is crazy good me Le is
crazy good especially you know in uh in
faster time
formats all right so stopping F5 makes
sense uh how would yeah
okay I guess this isn't too ambitious
but it's better to be very solid than
too ambitious that's why I often lose
games uh I mean okay you could call them
dramas whenever something like this is
unfolding in the world and you could say
I'm neutral but I'm just uh
reporting it as it
is I need to start the videos yelling
like Hikaru welcome back everyone oh I
had no idea Hikaru says
that yeah it's a bit weird you know for
for
newcomers but you know I guess I guess
it works
yeah
do I have any Pokemon Plushies in the
back no I don't have any Pokemon I do
have uh one that I got for my daughter
it's a it's a pretty big Pikachu plushy
uh but you just don't have any good ones
to buy here like you have the fake ones
and um they just look weird the color is
weird and the the shape of the body is
weird so yeah although I do like Pokemon
you know as much as the next guy I don't
want like a weird Charmander
you know like a like a pale pale orange
one all right who do we have still okay
let's go uh into beyond the top 10 we
have maner here vladimirovich uh
Anonymous uh a wonder leang is here okay
let's check out
him I don't remember seeing him and he's
uh he's playing against uh uh I know who
I know who Magnus Carlson 77 is from
Ukraine but I I I I will not disclose it
as he won second place last year in this
tournament so he's of course hoping to
do very well in this one as
well any plans on making a video on uh
Anand winning the World Championship
yeah definitely definitely I am
uh I even covered the the the first game
of the candidates matches between Magnus
and leevon uh from 2007 today uh you
know which unfold
by Anand winning the actual World Chess
Championship
tournament uh but yeah I'm I'm
definitely looking forward to covering
it in its
entirety uh butan still is not retired
uh from classical or you know from any
time format so I will probably do that
once he fully retires still you know I
like I could be making an Anan Saga now
and the guy decides he he's playing in
the candidat tournament if he wants he
can play uh and then you know what have
I done
what do I prefer for the candidates New
or Old
Blood uh best would be to just organize
a four four player tournament you know
uh Anish Wesley bukes and
uh uh GES and
um so can't remember the name
now come on guys help me out here my my
my brain brain stopped functioning I'm
I'm awake since 3 am. no no not Prague
not Prague prag is already qualified for
the candidates tournament and
alza uh yeah like you have uh you make a
four four player tournament and then who
qualifies qualifies and
uh that or you could increase the number
of players from eight to like 12 and
then you really let everyone join in no
no not Nepal yeah sorry my brain stopped
working yeah and a Wonder Le takes this
one from uh last year's second place
winner uh Magnus Carlson spelled
backwards uh all right who do we have is
anyone joining late snaro also playing
from usbekistan very nice very nice a
lot of strong players here uh last year
who won who won first place last year
yakub yeah nor yakub won first place
last
year uh I don't think anyone is
berserking here he's just lower on
time banir Ian that's uh that's very
nice to hear thank you very much for
that no it's not not definitely not
Kevin
sprag yeah the the you know the future
of Chess will be fought between the uh
usbekistan kids and
the uh and the uh kids from India and
also you know ala if he decides to play
a real chess and the serious chess so it
will be you know usbekistan India and
dza and also okay of course you will
have Vincent kimer and there are some
other very strong players but I meant as
a
nation post more videos of playing rapid
on Lees I I post One A Day how much do
you
want kakin versus Anand 2006 vikon such
a brilliant game I will check it out I
don't know the the the game or even the
theme of the game of course I don't know
every game but even games I haven't
shown I know maybe a theme about why the
game should be
shown all right wonderand leang really
crushing everyone but it's still uh Min
Le who lost one game and then is on a re
real winning
streak Kosik yeah yeah of course I
remember Kolkata
India one plus one is just too low is it
too low or too
slow where did ala go I don't know maybe
he's giving everyone a head start or
maybe he lost a game or two and uh
decided nah I'm just going to bail
this what's my take on who will win the
candidates uh uh well that's hard to say
since we don't know who will be in the
candidates I mean it could still change
but for those who are qualified for sure
you know not uh counting the last two
spots even though okay probably now
Wesley is getting the rating
spot uh yeah I don't know it's hard to
it's hard to pick a favorite when fabbi
is playing because well he already won
the candidates tournament once and you
could argue that he is now even stronger
than he was back uh uh in 2018 when he
fac
Magnus yeah I did hear ala withdrew from
the world rapid and Blitz Championship
but not as to why he
withdrew one why not one plus zero I
already mentioned that I have no no like
agenda here or a specific reason why not
1 plus Z instead of 1 plus one is just
that uh I thought maybe you know make it
okay I do want it to be bullet but maybe
let's make it uh sort of a serious event
where you don't just flag people uh but
yeah definitely I will do one where it's
1 plus zero as I also myself Play One
Plus Z I don't play one plus one I just
thought you know more serious players
would prefer one plus one but I I could
also be
wrong all right mpro just uh yeah
crushing everyone here I don't know who
who chess is is Frederick Swan oh Swan
is here very
nice yeah mpro really he has a 10-point
lead on everyone else and it's not going
to be easy to catch up to him especially
with Matias now after His Brilliant
winning streak he lost two in a row uh
but who is seesaw
effect seesaw effect yeah I'm pretty
sure pretty sure I've seen him in the
previous
tournament yeah we'll
see yeah yes my my favorite player is
Tal
definitely you know if if if I'm being
objective about it I could of course
name many other players but you know I
said it's tall long time ago it's tall
let's not let's not touch that any
anymore sometimes I indicate a move that
is just not good but I don't explain why
uh maybe I I think it's uh fairly
obvious and then it doesn't require
explaining or maybe I'm completely
missing the point and then then I should
be explaining it uh and I'm not so many
many possibilities
there oh Hans is uh oh it's Hans on
Twitch I thought it was Hans on Twitch
yeah like uh some dude named Hanson okay
but it's actually Hans on Twitch so that
is Hans nean
okay uh MSB winning this one very nicely
done uh yeah and uh mood Pro still going
very strong yeah mean l mean l just
crushing
everyone you lost two games three games
in a row and that was too much for you
three games is nothing like I lose three
games when I wake up in the
morning ah you were born on T's birthday
but he forgot to pass on the chess kill
yeah that's a that's a hard hard
one Hans is the most interesting player
in chess right now uh well depends on
what do you mean by
interesting he definitely does uh bring
the viewers
in and he is
strong yeah he can he can definitely
play against everyone he plays very very
Fighting Chance chess uh even though
okay in the last tournament he he did
get outplayed pretty pretty badly by
some players uh but you know so so so do
does everyone
else do I plan on becoming a title
player in the future what do you mean I
am a title player man I'm I'm a
candidate
Master how how much more title do you
need who is uh Grandmaster Athena palada
from
England yeah that's a good question okay
that pawn is now going
places okay it's going to be a nice
race nope
flagging flagging it
is all right so seesaw lost the game and
uh meanless still going uh still going
strong what's that like yeah it's like
15 wins in a row incredible
B is Dr
spicy no no I'm not I'm not a f
candidate Master no I'm just a national
candidate
Master yeah it's uh see the problem is
uh when I was still an active player
most of the games that I played were not
fed
rated
uh but now I just uh don't play I play
like uh very few events and when when I
got my when I finally got my feed rating
it was around 2,000 and something like I
could have gotten I I could have gotten
it like the candidate Master title but
then I played like a really terrible
event and uh at that time you still lost
a lot of points for games and you gained
a lot of points for g games so I dropped
it down to like maybe, 1900 and uh over
the course of the years now that I play
like maybe one tournament a year I did
get it up to
like I I have no idea to
what uh
I should check but yeah like may maybe
close to
2,000 so
it's if I if I wanted to I could get it
uh to CM that shouldn't be an issue to
FM I don't think so for that I would
really have to commit which uh of course
now uh don't really have time for
that yeah but some maybe 15 years ago
yeah it would be it would
be very very
enjoyable but back then yeah I remember
there were like maybe four four
tournaments that were fed rated that I
could play in Croatia and there were
really big ones you had to take like 10
days off and uh you had to travel they
weren't really uh near to where I live
and it was uh I I I think I did play I
played like in one and that was the one
where I lost all of those points it was
the the first event where I actually
played strong players
I'm my take on
uh uh rating farming uh I I don't think
it's that relevant yeah okay just Knight
captures yeah that works no Knight
captures Pawn no doesn't Okay uh it's
hard to say I mean uh depends on from
where you're coming uh of course Wesley
who is qualified for the candidates via
the rating spot uh of course his opinion
will be that it's unethical and uh if
you had players who were maybe close to
him not just ala if anyone else was
close to him like he needed uh one
tournament to
play uh Fay allowed it I mean uh a year
a year back you couldn't do something
like this because it was uh an average
rating over the course of the entire
year but then F said no that's too
boring let's just change it uh uh
highest rating as of January uh 2004 and
now everyone's like but what is this
yeah I mean that's the result that's uh
that that's what fed created fed created
this mess not the players doesn't matter
if it's alza it could be it could be 50
other players it could be 100 other
players if you know they were fairly
close to Wesley in
rating
uh it's been an issue uh for a very long
time should the should the rating spot
be eliminated
and uh okay they could have eliminated
it but why they made it like highest
rating of January like for one month
like you could be you could be
2600 for the entire year and then G gain
uh 100 like 200 rating points and you
will qualify for the candidates
tournament via rating it's uh like you
could literally Farm all you want and
they made they made it possible with
such a silly
rule
yeah it's definitely more of a system
problem now okay of course Fabby says
it's something I would never do of
course he wouldn't do it he qualified in
seven different ways uh so it doesn't
really makes sense he would never be in
a position where he would have to
consider such a thing and even alza if
you take uh for example before playing
his last tournament he was like 20
points higher rated than Wesley if he
really wanted he could have just bail on
that tournament and qualify without
without without an issue but I guess he
thought he would probably qualify you
know at least in some way and then he
lost a lot of rating and then you know
it kind of uh didn't didn't go through
for
him uh but yeah if he wanted he could he
could have also just set on his rating
and he would be by far the highest rated
player so it's uh not the best I mean
uh who would be toughest opponent for
ding I'm pretty sure Karana or nepo but
we already seen nepo playing ding so I'm
pretty sure uh people would uh prefer to
see someone else and we've also seen
Faby playing Magnus so you know nepo got
his chance Fab got his
chance uh you know maybe maybe Prague
takes it maybe prog takes the prog
challenges D who
knows oh but but your question was
stylistically stylistically who would be
the toughest opponent for
ding I don't know Fabi and ding playing
that would that would be like a clash of
a clash of
engines didn't ding say in an interview
that he struggles with Hikaru yeah okay
he struggles with
Hikaru where I mean in a in in Rapid in
Blitz in bullet uh I don't think ding
struggles against anyone in classical
and you know preparing for someone for a
classical match that's completely
different than anything you've played so
far in your life and ding does have the
experience in playing a a world CH
championship match so that's uh I think
it's a bit
different but yeah also I mean Fabby
Fabby has the experience of playing
Magnus in World CH championship match
and nio has the experience of playing
Magnus in world championship match uh
you you don't get more experience than
that like once you face Magnus in world
championship
match uh yeah but yeah NEPA faced first
Magnus then ding and it was uh it was
brutal so if nepo qualifies again that
would be that would be very
impressive I mean just the just the
willpower to to you know go to go at it
again is uh incredible in itself
yeah you need 30 uh classical games uh
for the for the rating spot or maybe
it's 33 or something like
that yeah okay you say that Magnus see
if he wanted to he could just win the
candidates outright and then beat anyone
in a world CH championship match but how
would you motivate Magnus to you know
take spend uh like four four four to six
months of his life you know for for
preparation for the candid then
preparation for the match uh for
something that he already had for for so
long and gave up
willingly uh I don't I don't see that
happening like he did of course uh uh he
did talk about it with Fay and they were
trying to figure out a way on how Magnus
would play whether to change the
structure of the of the world CH
championship match let's maybe not make
it like 12 or 14 classical games but
maybe uh introduce other formats as well
but yeah I mean then it's no longer a
classical world championship
match and uh but yeah I mean everywhere
where where you have uh tournaments now
they are decided on a tie break and tie
breaks are then you know classical goes
into rapid rapid goes into blizz blizz
goes into Armageddon uh but that's the
thing I mean even now you have a world
CH championship match consisting of like
12 classical games maybe we we see what
it will be for this cycle uh if that's
drawn it goes into rapid like it has
gone in for every wch championship match
you know since um uh yeah okay nepo now
broke the cycle as he lost In classical
to Magness but uh yeah it's uh it's
interesting I mean winning a world CH
championship classical world
championship match by by an Armageddon
game I mean that'd be that'd be pretty
crazy you know but it doesn't matter how
you do it you know kaspar and karpov
tried playing uh to six wins and you you
know how that turned out you know you
you end up in a
hospital ohanyan with one second on the
clock but we he does have one second
increment the biggest problem is
commentary of big events you can't watch
it the problem is okay uh you have a you
have a classical game and the classical
game and lasts for like 7even hours and
uh sure you you have like uh if you have
like uh Peter Sidler commenting he will
actually comment on the game for for 7
hours he will analyze it for 7 hours he
will be exhausting I mean it will be
exhausting for him like he's the one
that's playing the game uh but then
again yeah you have uh you have
commentators who sometimes
maybe discuss other things uh you know
other than chess for maybe like
uh couple of minutes maybe half an hour
and then
they go go back into chess and then you
have you know older Grand Masters who
comment like Yer seran who can who can
pretty much talk for 12 hours straight
about Chess and it would still be
incredibly interesting like he would see
this position and oh yeah that's the
position I remember I saw that like 50
years ago when Coro was playing in a
park I was having a really big juicy
sandwich and you know he remembers
everything about the game and uh yeah
also you have commentators like that but
those are now very
rare no we we did not get all of our
Gladiators for the candidates because uh
we still have no idea seven more days uh
we don't know who will get the the
rating spot uh I mean other tournaments
could still appear some farming
tournaments and uh well depending on uh
how the world rapid and Blitz
Championship goes it will be decided uh
who wins the fiday circuit now for the
moment it is G I think he overtook Anish
with some two or three points uh but if
Anish W wins the Rapid or or Blitz World
Championship then Anish takes
it or I'm pretty sure there are other
people who could as well take it
uh yeah someone already asked but I
don't mind I mean uh my view on farming
events is absolutely irrelevant well I
mean you you just don't allow that if
you allow it it doesn't matter if if one
person Farms or if 100 people Farm the
system allowed it and people will
farm and uh you know last year it was
not possible F just made it possible for
this year for the first time ever and
now they're like what is this what have
we
done ah only Arjun if he wins world
Rapid or Anish if he gets top three in
World rapid uh or Blitz wins okay so
really so it's uh only between Arjun and
Anish that can overtake gash now okay
it's good to
know glad to share it with everyone if
it's true
you have 99 farming in RuneScape can you
qualify for the
candidates not sure
but should be should be possible
yeah the way f is making the rules uh I
don't I don't see it being
impossible who is uh maybe next time who
is grandmas maybe next time I don't know
this
one Anish coming top three isn't
impossible of course not Anish could
very well win both of them
yeah yaser is one of the best
commentators in all sports in in your in
your opinion but yeah in my opinion as
well like you could just listen to yaser
talk about
anything like he's uh I mean he's an
amazing player uh in his days and even
now he's extremely strong but yeah he he
he's really a wonderful
commentator alza was playing at the
beginning of the tournament but then he
just
disappeared like lately he just appears
in events and then
disappears Anish has never gotten top
three in a world rapid
event okay well you you he also didn't
win Tata steel until he won Tata steel
that's how tournaments
work yeah yaser turns chess documenting
into a nature documentary he definitely
does
yeah ah no Panda says uh thank you for
for the input Panda that ala is still
playing uh he's number 35 as he has some
losses yeah but it's a I mean it's a
strong tournament you you can't expect
to just come and
win
Skyline
Inferno versus grandmas maybe next time
yeah I'm pretty sure I've seen maybe
next time in previous tournaments I just
can't remember who it
is uh oh that's uh sarana maybe next
time is Alexis Sara
okay yeah this is uh almost fully packed
like uh aside from the aside from the
top 20 uh we have a sort of a world
bullet Championship
here uh I'm not teaching my kids chess
as for the moment I only have one child
one on the way uh but uh and she's two
and a half but we do we do you know set
up pieces from time to time and then I
ask her like okay do you want to set up
pieces some more then we you know do how
the horse he moves uh and uh you know uh
takes like maybe 10 to 15 minutes max
and then she's like no then we do
something
else uh anid gowani yeah thank you thank
very
much sarana down to 66 seconds if that
is him I'm trusting people in the chat
you know sometimes that isn't wise but
I'm fairly sure my my viewers would not
trick me into believing someone is
someone who they are
not any info on rajabov where is he uh
not sure I haven't seen him or heard
from him in a while but I've seen him on
Twitter like like yesterday he posted
something uh so I'm you know I'm
guessing he's okay but he does disappear
you know even for years from time to
time then he comes back then he
disappears
again uh that's how he
rolls yeah never trust
chat
do I have any serious goals on improving
my rating no not at
all not at all at the
moment you know when I when I you know
will be in a different uh uh position in
life where maybe I will have uh a couple
of hours every day that I could use
maybe to to brush up on my on my chest
maybe but for the moment no not
really uh I'm mostly I I mean I play
every day like first thing I wake up you
know I uh you know first do the hygiene
then uh work out a little bit then uh
you know once uh you know my daughter is
in kindergarten then I play at least
three games of of Blitz uh then if I win
those I'm very happy and I start my work
if not then I play a few bullet games uh
you know until I win of course to
improve my mood uh and then I and then I
work yes I do YouTube fulltime for a for
a couple of years
now uh maybe even six years now I would
say all right so what's the lineup after
an hour of the tournament we have two
and a half thou two and a half thousand
people playing uh and uh minan Le from
Vietnam still with first place but he
did uh put in a couple of losses and now
ciso effect is catching up with 64
points yeah Matias blue bomb also very
close with 61 points we have uh yor
kosev uh in fourth this is sarana Alexis
sarana you guys said in number five
vladimirovich Thunder Warrior we have no
idea who that is but they also in the
top 10 I break you chess F and uh chess
mood chess M Grandmaster
gabusan uh all right let's see who does
have a who has a fresh game okay this
looks like a pretty wild position okay
we can check up on some of the beyond
the top
holy Kebab when are the sagas returning
I am uh planning on the Stein Saga I
know that it's been going on for a while
uh but I seriously do hope to to get it
going in January it's been really a long
time since I promised that I know and
believe me there is nothing I would love
more than to share myit knowledge with
you uh but I'm I'm guessing January it
will finally
happen no Anan Saga no because Anan is
still a very much an active
player Oh Magnus will not lose his
championship titles it's not like Magnus
is going to the world rapid and Blitz to
defend his title of world rapid and
Blitz Champion it's uh I don't think
it's viewed that way I mean it's it's an
open Event everyone plays against
everyone uh and he's still by far the
the favorite to win it I I think both
the rapid and Blitz uh but I don't I
wouldn't view it as losing his champion
champion
title it's merely a title that uh gets
vacated every
year what's my day job my day job is uh
following everything that happens in the
Chess World and then my night job is
sharing it with everyone more or
less all right let's check okay
vladimirovich already finishing up his
game okay this okay leang has an
interesting position
against against Matthew
G consider dubbing for Marvel villains
you have a you have that voice yeah I
don't know which uh which villain you
had in
mind am I a chess trainer well I do
train people every day via my
videos uh not in a good way but I'm
pretty sure they get something out of
them ding is 22 points higher rated than
Magnus in Rapid now yeah okay I
mean doesn't really mean all that much
dink can win magn be beat Magnus and
Magnus could can beat the ding but
statistically Magnus will beat the ding
more
often that Dr Octopus of course yeah Dr
Octopus has anyone ever thought about
hosting a nameless event so the
opponents wouldn't be aware of who they
are playing against that would mitigate
mag the Magnus effect yeah okay but uh
but I'm pretty sure every leas Arena
that Magnus played in he played under a
different name and then of course once
he started winning everyone understood
who he was but up until this point uh
yeah you didn't
know uh didn't uh didn't Eric Rosen like
beat Magnus uh uh in that game un leas
where he didn't know he was playing
Magnus I think he did yeah and then uh
later on you know everyone figured out
who who Magnus was and then he was like
I think he even made a video on it and
he said that it's a good thing that he
didn't know he was playing against
him okay ala starts really winning some
games and he's up to number four
now yeah so he stopped messing
around we'll see if he can if he can
take it all the
way yeah I don't think he played last
year or maybe he
did yeah I don't know uh but he didn't
uh at least uh win any
prizes as far as I as far as I can
remember
who among gu alaish and Wesley do I want
to qualify for the candidates I don't
have any special wishes regarding that
you know
who uh who who deserves the to join the
candidates should join the candidates I
would I I mean I would love to see all
of them
in but other than that I mean it's up to
feay to to create the
criteria uh of course you know that from
Wesley and danish you can expect uh high
quality games and you've already seen
them playing in the candidates and uh
you you know that uh everything is
everything is good if they are playing
but you also want to give the the young
players an opportunity so it's I mean
it's basically how they how they manage
to get to the candidates okay this is
nice wow they are very fast
here yeah Anish also has high quality
tweets so we should also take that into
consideration about his uh spot in the
candidates should also be like
uh part of the Fay circuit they should
also you know uh award a certain amount
of points for for quality of tweets but
who would rate that like if twe if twe
if Feer rated that uh who knows how how
they would rate
it yeah the greatest secret Magnus was
when he absolutely crushed J Gustafson
during one of his banard Blitz streams
yeah that was a really an amazing
one uh when Gustafson thought he was
playing against a cheater like he was
like uh yeah his moves are so good I
mean he's just destroying
me can Anand qualify for the candidates
not uh not this uh particular uh
candidates tournament but you know if he
wanted to of course he
could msb2 is Maas blue bomb yeah it has
a playing
two and uh he's down to 30 seconds so
we'll see he he is up two
pawns
but uh it is a it is a plus one like you
don't it's not like you have 20 seconds
in bullet this is a plus one he can play
a 100 more
moves
yeah I don't know uh like I said we do
have the 50 game requirement to avoid
the cheaters as much as possible but if
someone really wants they can just play
50 rated games and you know create a new
account and then then they cheat uh but
the system will fairly quickly catch up
to them and they will be disqualified
from the event at least that's how it's
been so
far
what do I think about Shak Mader's
playing
style well he's a I mean he's an
absolute
Beast uh he has an incredible style very
sharp style he he he's great in
everything it's merely a matter of uh
you know how what what kind of a day
he's having and you know what kind of an
event he's having but if he has a good
day he can you know da Dazzle everyone
and you know defeat everyone from any
position why don't why don't I show the
evaluation bar in my videos um yeah res
a loses uh I I will not tell you who
this is uh because it's a secret but he
does
lose
yeah yeah Maas versus Wonder leang
shock seems like the most tall like
super
GM um really mov you would say is most
tall
like oh probably probably rort would be
the most tall like super GM aside from
like dubov but dubov you know fluctuates
with rating too much to be uh in the in
the top top 10 or top top 15 top 20 uh
but yeah I think from from people who
you know Peak into the the top 10 and
maybe peek out uh a rapport would be
closest to tals playing
style no it's not a it's not like a big
secret who who defeated ala but uh since
I know who it is and it's it doesn't say
in the in the profile I will not
disclose
it yeah it is a very good question how
does it like playing at that level with
uh with that style you know it does lose
him a couple of games that maybe he
really shouldn't lose H but then again
he does create some absolute
brilliancies
all right who do we have maybe a nice
position or starting what is happening
here what is
this
am mini Saga for engines there is much
drama especially with Kasparov they
deserve it after all since they are the
strongest player now yeah I I I am
planning a sort of a a short history of
computer chess maybe over the course of
10 videos like a 10 10 show like a 10
miniseries
uh also probably in
January uh is it's something I always
wanted to do uh but now I'm I'm actually
going to do
it you know from the from the beginnings
to to to Alpha zero probably will stop
there will there will there ever be a
4,000 rated engine I I'm pretty sure
like the strongest engine now is like
rated four 4600 so I don't I don't think
it's a problem to be rated four 4,000
but uh doesn't also matter that much
especially for for humans
you know one day the engine will say I
remember I don't remember what year it
was exactly but some version of fritz or
stockfish like
maybe in 2006 like put put a question
mark on on the French defense like on
the uh Black's first move like what is
this stockfish is 3600
okay yeah but I mean it's merely a
matter of time they have to they have
the beef of the rating every year if
they are you know planning on selling it
somehow you hope the third Indian
qualifies for the candidates yeah at
some point it was almost uh almost
four Indians in the uh candidates
possibility yeah I don't know I don't
know if it was stockfish or some other
engine I know it was either yeah I think
it it was stockfish but yeah I like put
a question mark on on the theen
defense
what do I think of n abasov in the
candidates uh I mean it's very well
deserved okay he did the qualify uh via
third place because Magnus of course
decided not to play uh but I mean anyone
who tried playing that tournament did
not get third place so it's well well
deserved yeah I I don't really have an
answer to who is the goat in chess it's
uh I mean you you have too many
incredible players like it's always it's
always the same answer like it's it's
it's Kasparov it's Magnus it's
Fisher uh that's pretty much it and you
can't really you can't really save
Fisher Okay as as impressive as Fisher
was from like 1969 to
1972 uh that's three years you've had
Kasparov who's been dominant over over
over like two decades uh not like number
one but uh he was absolutely Sensational
and then you had Magnus who was uh world
number one for over over 10 years uh
yeah you could uh depending on the
criteria you you would have to change
your opinion on who the goat is but if
if you're going with longevity uh then I
mean qu there's uh only want answer
Kasparov uh yeah let's check out this
one so you
know yeah lasar was number one for 27
years but that was a different time back
then lasar could choose opponents he
could say okay I do accept the match and
the match will happen in two years time
uh if you've been following the
capablanca Saga you know how how
difficult it was for capablanca to
actually organize a match with lasar
like they had uh three months of just
sending letters and uh deciding on who
who gets the rights to the moves after
the the match is played like it was uh
Madness so lasker's 27 years aren't
really what you would uh have in today's
time yeah it's very very much
different tal is very much a goat but
for me tal what tal cannot be considered
like T you know I think bwick called tal
and smist of the two winter Kings you
know they they they were like comets
they just uh Rose quickly but they fell
really quickly it wasn't uh it it wasn't
their longevity or anything that made
them specially it was uh especially for
tal it was his style the the way he
played the way he the way he con
conquered the the the chess
Olympus uh that was uh you know
something completely different than what
was uh seen then like they called him
the pirate because he would just you
know he would just uh steal and Thief
his way into into Victory from any
position who was the worst world chess
champion in my opinion well okay I'm
guessing if if there are you know if
there are a couple of world champions
someone has to be the best and someone
has to be the worst but again under what
what
criteria what would you mean by the
worst am I going to bring back podcasts
well I I I was planning on uh if there
will be something but now whenever
there's a drama whenever there's
something to be discussed like everyone
does that uh I don't I don't feel like
uh me doing a podcast now with someone
about the drama as that is what everyone
is talking about would contribute in any
way and you do have like the the C squar
podcast by uh by Christian and Fab I
mean that's uh they pretty much follow
everything and they cover everything and
it's really really good so yeah if if if
you're not if you guys aren't following
that yeah you should definitely uh check
out the the C squar
podcast but uh yeah if there will be
some sort of topic that I could discuss
with someone and you guys would really
enjoy seeing it and maybe someone hasn't
covered it from that angle I wouldn't
mind doing like a doesn't matter like a
1 hour two hour conversation with
someone yeah every an each tweet is an
episode when will you see me on c
squared uh I've actually talked to to
karwana when he was in Croatia briefly
during the the tournament in Zagreb and
and with Christian and they said that
they would love to have me on a podcast
but in person and uh that's pretty much
how I would enjoy having it I wouldn't
really I've tried having it with mvl and
with hiar when I started my podcasts
online but it's just not the same you
know it's much better when you have a
person next to you in the room then you
can sort
of uh get a better I don't know a better
temperature let's let's call it that uh
it's very much different when you're
when you're on a call with someone like
I did enjoy my my call briefly with with
Benjamin at the start of this stream how
but it would be much better if he was
like here you know maybe we have a beer
or or not but you know it's still better
in
person no I don't have any updates on Al
as race to the candidates uh if I will
have any I will definitely let let you
guys
know when did I realize the B4 is the
mighty Square it happened very early on
in my chess
career uh you know I I started uh first
I started with some morphe games then I
I watched some uh Anderson games my
grandfather had a lot of uh uh really
old books and then he had like a series
of old books on each of these great
players not just on like really old on
one Onin and on Alin and on I don't know
andelman and like and in you know in
every one of the the games that everyone
deemed the most important ones or their
evergreen or Immortal games before
played a crucial role and uh you know
now that I'm analyzing chess games every
day and I'm always looking for where's
the Breakthrough I know I know where
it's going to happen I know it's going
to be on the B4 square there's no
avoiding that like even this game Rook
B4 ends the game I mean it's everywhere
it's like uh could be also one of those
uh effects like uh you know look for it
and you will see it but um no I'm pretty
sure it's the strongest Square in
[Music]
general you call B4 bman why why would
you call it
bman uhuh in the beginning of the
tournament ala played a lot of games
with only 30 seconds on the clock yeah
that's called berserking he gives up
half of half of his time and then he
gets an extra point for a win uh but I'm
guessing it didn't go uh all that
well yeah Shan thank you for enjoying my
rapid
games I I do very much enjoy playing
them all right
and alza resigns against International
Master Green
Knight yeah not easy for ala to catch a
streak and at this level uh killer
Bishop yeah had a wonderful streak but
then three losses in a row yeah this is
a oh this is a still a slugfest I mean
everyone's uh here like 79 78 77 77 like
could be could go either way like if uh
if anyone starts playing really well
who's D 94 from
USA Grandmaster
D I will check after the
game what do I recommend against the
Catlin uh I don't know what's it called
uh or do I I don't know how to play
against the Catlin but uh there is a
variation that the dubov plays against
the Catalin and it involves a very early
Pawn sacrifice and it's just uh just
very nice and very
enjoyable uh I have no
idea how it goes uh I've checked on it
like a couple of weeks ago but I will I
will make a video on it I will make a
video on
it yeah I I remember when I saw it I was
like oh yeah now Duba finally shows us
the way how to treat the Catlin uh
without you know investing a million
hours in
theory no I don't think Dar is
nitki uh pretty sure he has a pretty
standard H Dar SCH yeah okay I mean I
could have could have guessed as it's
Dar yeah so it's Dar
SCH uh minan Le still leading the
tournament he's been leading for the
entire event I
think yeah but still uh 40 minutes left
in the arena uh definitely could go
either
way I haven't stopped covering dubbo's
gam so whenever dubov plays a game I'm
the first one to check it
out when did I start playing the Evans
Gambit when uh you know after after I
first saw it uh that was
it uh but yeah it was definitely you
know a long long time ago when I first
saw the Evergreen
game
sort of the the first immortal game
where where the Kings Gambit would was
used uh was incredibly impressive and
also the Opera House game uh was
incredibly impressive I mean that's the
game you show to everyone that's sort of
the Opera House game is the the essence
of Chess itself uh but uh yeah when I
saw the Evergreen game uh that was when
I knew that Evans Gambit is the the
greatest thing you could ever
see
yeah the Netflix show did do a lot for
chess to make it mainstream uh far more
than I ever
expected yeah I I I I had no idea uh it
would make such a boom and to this day I
still have no idea why it made such a
boom I know a lot of people you know
discussed that and there are many you
know yeah it's because of this it's
because of this but you know tell you
the truth I like for real have no idea
why it made such a big
boom
yeah I need to try some London system to
improve that I uh I don't think I will
ever play a game of London system in my
life first I'm not a D4 player and even
but if I was I would probably be a
London system player
yeah that's uh you know it's not the
best but what are you going to
do uh but I think it was uh Fabiano yeah
Karana versus uh penguin or versus
Andrew tang in the US Chess Championship
he played Andrew went for the London
system against Fabby and Fabby went uh
very interesting line yeah he went for
the early D5 G6 uh and then he attacked
the the bishop with Knight the H5 right
away and then uh Bishop E5
um Andrew attacked the the rook and
Fabby defended it even with Pawn to F6
then Bishop went back and then he played
C6 it was a really weird setup but I
mean that game if you haven't seen it uh
Tang versus Fabby beautiful beautiful
how Fabby completely dismantles it uh
and just shows that you know the London
system is just really bad okay this was
this was uh beautifully
done Contra yako uh okay seems to be
just starting up he's playing against
the Grand Master castroso from
Chile Chris
welcome and thank you thank you for the
kind
words Kasparov TV series could be
amazing yes could and uh greetings Andre
handela very very very good guy knows a
lot about Chess very strong
player do I think there is going to be a
third massive chess platform in the near
future uh actually yes I think there's
going to be a really massive platform in
the very near
future I do think that for whatever
reason yeah ding versus Napa World CH
Championship Match six the London
system uh yeah I mean it does uh it does
allow you for some beautiful uh
attacking possibilities I mean the
London really does allow you to play
whatever without without actually
conceding too much sort of like you're
doing nothing and uh your opponent can't
really hone in on a weakness uh and then
you just overtake the entire game so
it's you have to be really really
careful with black I mean that's
basically the story of every opening but
I don't know it just feels like uh if
you face the London unprepared you you
you know you start hating chess uh real
soon I I could try to say I didn't
finish but I'm just uh I have no idea
how I would say
that hia
yua yeah hia yua I don't
know
what would be the business model for the
third big platform I have no idea I am
not a
businessman yosip shocket ah yosip
greetings any preference between regular
London or Tor uh I don't know the Tor
London I don't know if you mean the the
Tor system or is there indeed uh a
London system version that is called the
Tor
London uh yeah karang Gupta I did make a
tutorial on how to destroy the uh London
system with the C5 and early Queen to B6
but it's uh as I found in my own games
it's uh actually very very difficult to
play this it's very difficult to play
this system that I came up with uh
because I was I didn't use any previous
knowledge or any uh systems I just uh
allowed the engine to feed me moves like
the strongest moves like give me uh you
know depth 60 of every move and then I
just come up with a defense for black
that's how I came up with that one and
while it is Ironclad it's uh I don't
know I found that it's very fairly
difficult to play at at somewhat higher
level uh whereas uh the the game that I
mentioned where Fabby defeated Andrew
Tang uh seems to be a more natural way
of
developing uh I mean at least for a
human Scorpion or Subzero I'm going to
go with Subzero since your handle uh
here on YouTube is
Subzero uh but no I'm I'm lying of
course scorpion yeah who who are we
kidding is English opening one of the
most difficult to play I don't know as I
don't play it and I don't uh know how to
play against it I just play the the
hyper accelerated dragon against the
Sicilian and then whatever white does in
the center I adapt uh but no I've
actually never done any serious work on
how to play with or against the
English don't be sad Subzero Subzero
also has uh some some great moments
uh and also which one are you referring
to as there are two Subzero no the they
are
brothers it's been a while since I've
brushed up on my Mortal Kombat
lore Chris Rain only ever plays the bong
Cloud yeah that is one way to do it that
is one way to do it if you want to you
know prove your Supremacy to to everyone
yeah seeing Andrew Tang beating Leela
was one of the coolest chess games ever
yeah yeah that was uh but that was a was
that like a bullet or even a hyper
bullet game uh and Andrew defeated Leela
that was rated
like
3200 unleashes at a time it was or maybe
it was still the training one but like
no Leela crushed him in a match I mean
severely but that one game yeah that was
incredibly impressive aggessive yeah it
was hyper yeah in bullet no the engine
is just too fast you you couldn't do
anything but in hyper Andrew was
faster yeah in hyper I believe like in
uh in 15 seconds in Ultra bullet uh you
know uh Andrew would probably just adopt
Leela I it was Ultra bullet okay sorry
yeah it's because it was Ultra
bullet how many videos do I record per
day as much as it's needed you know
depending depending on what the world
needs nice there are very a lot of
people streaming this tournament very
nice yeah uh if there's nothing
happening I show maybe some of the older
games like I did today I showed the 2007
game between Magnus and leevon but if
you know if it now we'll have the world
rapid and Bliss champion chionship uh I
will not show Shy Away from even showing
five games per
day yeah I I I stopped uh I I don't
really cover engine games all that much
nowadays uh since uh like if there was a
match I was following or maybe like if
they organize purely Evans Gambit match
between you know two powerful engines
Maybe i' cover something like that uh
but yeah generally I I will not do that
uh but yeah like I said yarov covers
engine games fairly often so for those
of you who like engine games do chess do
check out yar's chess
Channel he really uh investigates well
and uh shows very nice
ones my taste in music I don't really
listen to much music these days but uh
if I had to choose like I would
uh you know the older the
better like the the the really older the
better you know like like in chess
classical is
best any historical match you wished you
watched live like an entire match or or
or just a game
yeah I mean every every single one of
them every single one of
them yeah I mean okay I mean let's not
now say fisher versus uh tal I mean of
course not there isn't a person alive
who wouldn't want to see that but any
any match is perfectly fine imagine if
you could if you could go back to Paris
and watch a game between morphe and
Anders I
mean
uh there there are too
many start tigran pan Saga yeah we'll
get to tigran we'll get to the iron
tiger at some
point but our good friend schit is still
waiting did I cover the Hunt nean game
that made him a GM uh where he won with
zero
captures no pretty sure I
haven't
uh I'm pretty sure the only game on this
uh topic that I've covered is I think
goric maybe it's not goric Immortal but
it is gor's game where uh he also wins
without capturing a single piece and his
opponent also did not capture a single
pie so it's a a captureless Immortal if
you
will
and yeah I have it on the channel
alza not not crushing it definitely yeah
meanless still still just crushing
people yeah he loses like a game every
games that man is
good which game which country I belong
to I I'm uh I'm
catian Eric Rosen made a video on H GM
game okay I will check out the
game uh if you say that uh yeah I do
yeah I also have the captures captures
Immortal I have the the captur L
Immortal and the captures captures
Immortal Magnus versus Hikaru bullet
game bullet match 200 games who will win
uh depends whether it's on chess.com or
on Le chess also depends if it's real
bullet 1 plus Z or 1 plus one uh you
know depends on a lot
but probably
probably Hikaru has has a slight Edge I
would
say as a bullet is not just about
playing good chess yeah especially like
real one plus Z
bullet yeah this is now
crew yeah also depends what the weather
is
outside alza got destroyed by
jobava no Croatia is not in Russia
definitely not in
Russia uh who do we have here all right
MB yeah still the the top 10 don't seem
to be changing and okay we're up to
3,000 people in the event very nice
nice yeah some very very strong people
here but it's a very strong event so
even some very strong Grand Masters
can't make it into the top even top top
20 top 30 yeah but vladimirovich now
also on a on a killing
spree yeah very
nice and a very nice position at that
what is
this
oh he finds a nice one nice
nice favorite format bullet Blitz Rapid
or classical by far
classical by far
classical but I mean I if if strong
players are playing and I I will watch
anything why do I think pan and Smith of
are underrated world champions I I don't
think that at
all like no I don't think no anyone
thinks
that why don't I invite Anand for a
podcast I've stopped doing
podcasts like but yeah Anand would be I
think Anand would be the perfect guest
for a podcast it would be it would be
extremely enjoyable to have Anand uh as
a
guest
and uh yeah i' I bought his book and
I've read his book The mind master as
soon as it came out and it's uh like if
you if you guys have a chance to read it
uh you will really learn a lot about uh
Anand and then the world CH Championship
sagas and on the preparation going into
that and his personal life like it's a
really wonderful book uh especially if
you want to like I said know more about
Anand but yeah at some point I'm uh uh I
I am very much hoping into doing maybe I
don't want to call them podcasts but
like I would uh maybe like to have a
conversation or two with some
people uh I guess it's hard to say that
without calling it a podcast but uh
yeah Anand would be Anand would be sort
of a dream guest
definitely did I read the one minute
Checkmate by hikaro no I haven't but
sounds like sounds like a book he would
write
yeah do I have a favorite player right
now uh I don't know how I would
characterize a player being a favorite
of mine like if he was playing does it
bring me great joy I don't know like if
if dubo is playing uh then I I kind of
drop what I'm doing and I check out the
game uh so maybe you could you could say
Duo is is my
favorite
all right nice one starting
out the Seesaw effect oh this is uh I'm
pretty sure this is uh some top grandmas
top 20 Grandmaster who's just uh lazy to
you know fill out his
info this is the first time I've watched
your live stream and you are quite funny
my friend thank you Mr metal
fingers
yeah why metal
fingers how much hours of preparation
are done by Grand Masters every
day
o I don't know I'm pretty sure the the
young ones who are you know trying to
trying to overtake the world you know
they could be preparing for 10 hours a
day I don't
know
my favorite World Chess Championship
Match in terms of games
quality I do not have a favorite world
CH championship match in terms of games
quality uh but uh I mean I don't
know T tal bwick is is a match I would
recommend everyone to check out the
first
match and also the second match if you
want to see how how bini completely
changed his playing style and adapted to
T's uh you know happy Hunting Ground
Play
Style no it's okay nature at it at its
best place says that in my initial video
some five years ago five six years ago I
didn't like anan's play uh that's not
really that's not really the case I did
say that in one video uh but uh that was
a it was a sort of a different time
because I stopped following anything
that was happening in the Chess World
for like 10 years and I only came back
to following what's been happening maybe
in
2013 uh when Magnus was sort of getting
into the picture for real you know
started he won the candidates and he
started playing for the world CH
Championship again uh pretty much that's
where I came back into chess after a
long absence uh and I didn't mean that I
didn't like anan's games it's just that
uh I didn't know of any uh that I liked
but you know if you if you look I mean
there are such incredible games his uh
uh his victory against leevon in the uh
is it is it was it the Tata
steel or was it I don't remember if it
was the Tata steel or maybe it was
called the chorus back then but his his
game against Leon with the black pieces
where he just you know sacrificed
everything and wins it's one of the one
of the greatest games of modern chess so
yeah you can't really have uh can't
really say that Anam games are not
interesting like if you if you run into
his stuff or even if you just give him
room to you know play around yeah you're
you're
doomed will I cover more his medin of
games maybe at some point if I'll make
like a serious n medov Saga but I'm
pretty sure I covered all of the all of
the important n medov games like now if
I would be covering n medino games I
could like redo all of them like
remaster them in you know 4K 60 frames
per second you know for for better
enjoyment but uh I'm pretty sure I've
covered all of
them uh I don't think I know the game
game tall versus youth chess
School how to improve chess to a an
eight years kid books sorry
what I have no idea what to do with that
sentence sorry how to improve chest to a
8 years kid
books you have someone who is eight
years old and is trying to improve via
books how do you compare Magnus to Bobby
Fisher in terms of talent I don't know I
I'm it's way beyond my pay grade to make
such a
comparison like I'm guessing both of
them had an incredible and magnet still
has of course uh capability of
memorizing like they can memorize
everything as as much as they want and
they have
the probably the greatest fighting
Spirit ever in chess history would be
okay and Kasparov but uh as you as You'
asked me the you know comment between
Magnus and
Fisher yeah great greatest fighting
Spirit they they you know they'll do
everything and anything to win and their
opening knowledge is uh unrivaled like
okay you might have younger grandm today
who will outplay Magnus in the opening
maybe if they surprise him
because I really doubted that Magnus is
spending like 10 hours a day studying
Theory uh but
uh yeah in in you know in his youth uh
you know both Magnus and Fisher would be
like yeah he's uh their fighting spirit
and uh opening
prowess like I remember in I don't
remember which book it was but someone
described cried like Fisher's play maybe
it was Caris perhaps it was Caris but he
sort of described it as if you were
playing against the a room with no doors
or windows that and the walls were
closing in on you that's how like that
that's what it was like to play against
Fisher doesn't matter how many moves you
lasted 40 50 60 it was merely a matter
of time before you
cracked and also you could very easily
describe magnus's play in those terms
does access to digital chess provide an
advantage for modern day players that
were raised on it such as du or ala then
there's kaspar kic that's that got
access in their later life uh well I I
imagine it definitely helps uh whether
it's better I don't know probably will
make it better in terms of tournament
results
uh I don't know how better it will make
it in terms of uh
understanding but uh you know simply by
by measuring results of uh younger
players who who were raised by engines
against uh older players who started
without engines and got access to
engines uh you know one had one has to
go with engines I would
say
yeah Rahul I already uh mentioned
briefly you know everything uh I I was
planning on regarding the the race to
the candidates and Al's tournament I
think it's uh it's pointless to comment
on what ala is doing uh because ala is
doing it fed allowed it and they allowed
it specifically for this year it was not
possible last year it was not possible
in the 10 previous years and uh you
could have a situation where not just Al
you could have 20 players doing it
because it's possible and and it's uh
perfectly reasonable I mean to to some
extent uh because okay you had you could
say I don't know uh yeah but the chenai
grand Masters they were organized well
before you know they knew that Gish
would not qualify by other means uh but
yeah why wouldn't they just organize it
regardless of whether Gish qualifies via
other means and then if he qualifies you
know he just plays an additional
tournament no big deal and if he doesn't
he gets another chance like you could
also view it that way uh it all depends
on what angle you view it you know
through uh but you know it's silly the
nitpick what what anyone did it's Fay
who made it who made it
possible for to this day I have no idea
idea for what
reason yeah the ageold saying you play a
child you play an end game you win yeah
it's uh basically my strategy when I
played like one or two tournaments a
year and I face a younger player who
just trashes me in the opening like
absolutely destroys me and then I have
to go into an end game and play like uh
additional three hours in order to prove
that I'm better uh but yeah you know
I I I will pull it off this year but
next year once they get older it's not
going to be
easy will I personally visit the
candidates tournament and cover it
thoroughly ye no and
yes no and yes it is a bit far away uh
but I will cover it thoroughly
definitely
aution magard says please cover my game
I sent it via email okay but only if
it's a really good
game what what opening was
used you saw a video of levian Ky
playing Chile chess
they eat a piece they have to eat a
chili
pepper does it have a potential like
chess boxing well I know that's pushing
it a little bit but um you know if you
make it people will watch it I think
like
uh like the chess Bross made a video on
first I think Fabby played against uh
Aman Hamilton uh the the maybe it's not
the first but it's the first chili chess
match that I've seen uh and yeah I mean
people will watch that I mean people
watch chess they obviously watch people
eating chili for a contest uh you know
who can eat the most uh and most
terrible chili peppers in the world uh
so you know obviously people will watch
both of that both of those
things yeah the 1953 tournament series
please uh Paras uh paba chess speaks
well I I actually have the book here
it's staring right at me um but but uh
yeah it's uh it's quite an undertaking
and you know after I finish the shin it
Saga then I will slowly get into other
things that 1953 tournament
included I actually uh covered two games
the first two games of the book by
brunstein and uh yeah it's uh I mean
it's also an Incredible Book especially
from Bronstein's perspective as uh he
really gives you an insight into every
game how a grand Master thinks and also
he explains it very nicely how even
Grand Masters uh don't know how to think
properly like he says from like the 20
best Grand Masters at the event maybe
three of them are able to think at that
level and that they you know make a lot
of silly mistakes due to
that drunk chess boxing is the next big
thing low yeah
definitely
earlier I had a puppy yeah the puppy's
downstairs the me is always chilling
downstairs I will I I took him for a
walk before the stream and I will take
him for another one after we finish the
stream do I think chess is a sport well
if you've ever played a let's say a
serious Tournament game against the
strong opponent for six let's say six
maybe six and a half hours uh you you
would not be asking that
question was C 1953 a Dark Tournament
why why what do you mean a Dark
Tournament why what's the definition of
a Dark
Tournament okay Contra yako and
vladimirovich overtook Min Le for the
first time since the tournament started
so mean Le slows down a little bit and
ala speeds
up yeah look at this 8 minutes ala is on
a winning streak and he has the he has
the
flame alza has the
flame very interesting very interesting
turn of
events iaru spoke about playing chess
while driving a car well if he if he has
a Tesla like Fabby uh then it's no
problem best chess game is is the
opening scene of age of Empires
2 I I do not know that opening
scene what is the name me or Meo the
second one it's
Meo me's a me's a
boy was 1953 tournament controversial
where Soviets wanted Smith to win the
tournament and to stop
rvi uh
not to my knowledge but then again I'm
I'm not an expert on the 1953 Siri
tournament all right this is very
intense Al Resa down a
pawn not for
long no I'll raise up a
pawn yeah very interesting but down on
time but it doesn't matter now he's
up no
sorry I'll ra down two
pawns the the interface tricked
me what is my full-time job in terms of
earning excluding YouTube you really
think I have time outside of YouTube for
a job
yeah that's that's a good one uh best
chess advice you have ever
received
um yeah it's hard to say like for for
tournament play when when you just start
playing probably that I should sit sit
on my
hands but okay that's uh that's a good
advice I I've never really was a hasty
player I I I I I'm more of more strugger
more more more struggled with uh uh
playing too
slow yeah even in a classical game I
always use use up all of my
time yeah so alza lost that
one do you still photograph even for fun
no as I've never photographed I was uh
if you're referring to my previous job I
was a videographer for I videographed
weddings for like 10
years ala versus
Matias yeah ala does have a very very
much a positive score against him 142
wins uh to to 34
wins no no increment next time please
are will you be playing Mr Hain and ala
loses another one one yeah he probably
wanted to win really quickly to catch up
to everyone but now he lost yeah not the
best not the best all right let's check
out yor kosev doing extremely well
versus Contra
yako all right if you definitely will
play we'll do no increment next
time
yeah but best chess advice for like
beginners yeah you know the the usual
stuff watch uh what's the movie called
uh with Bruce pandini as the the tutor
of young Josh Whit
skin uh the Searching for Bobby Fisher
yeah check out that check out that movie
you will will have all the all the
necessary advice for for a young player
on how to start their
Adventure how is ala farming going yeah
he's not uh farming anymore the
tournament is over he he stopped at five
and a half out of
six you've been playing chess every day
for the past nine months with not
without improving well you will not be
improving by just playing chess yes you
will maybe improve your speed and you
will improve uh flagging if you play
shorter time performance but you will
not be improving your
chess how accurate was the movie Pawn
sacrifice uh no I I didn't like it at
all and I I I really read a lot of books
on Bobby and uh especially since I had I
did the entire Saga on Fisher and I just
uh felt it was completely wrong I didn't
like anything about the movie
as much as I like I mean I like to Toby
Maguire as much as the next guy but he's
not the the the man to play
Fisher yeah no increment is flaggers
bread and butter but yeah it's what
people
want yeah yor kosev wins it wins it very
nicely very
nice all right we are up to 3151 players
uh but that doesn't really change
anything uh about the top 10 and we have
two and a half minutes remaining with a
lot of people on 107 106 106 and Maas
also has the flame and uh if you have
the flame that means that if you win you
get the flame after you win at least
three games in a row that means that
every consecutive game that you win you
gain an additional point so having the
flame here uh is the good stuff
definitely Atul thank
you thank you for for being a huge fan
of the
channel uh I don't know Matias blue bomb
I think has the best chances as he does
have the
flame ah it's two in a row okay
sorry obviously it's been a while since
I've had the
flame yeah you could also say that that
being a flagger means that you're just
good at defending bad positions yeah
like Hikaru Hikaru will defend
anything also makes him a very strong
Flagger yeah Maas wins this one as well
and his streak continues and he takes
the lead with 110 points jagor also on a
huge winning streak but he is down a few
points and alza lost his streak but he
started berserking so it's going to be
crazy but Matias in the lead now facing
uh ktis from
Yemen very interesting
your puzzle rating is 2424 that is very
impressive you are very
strong can I dunk on a basketball hoop I
could in high
school yeah I could in high school but
now I I I cannot I don't I wouldn't even
try
oh Bruno going to finish around 100 well
if if it will be in the top 100 oh white
offered a draw here white doesn't want
to waste time playing this game for some
reason yeah why thinks that he's just up
uh too many points and doesn't want to
risk a
loss yeah very
interesting
oh it's a reference the Prison Break
season five canel atis yeah I I watched
prism break like a long long time ago
it's a really bad series like really bad
I don't know why I watched
it like okay I could I could swallow the
first season but uh you know everything
after that uh kind of uh too
much
yeah the top score is really
close Panda speaks
wise a wise Panda
indeed h house what what what about h
house
Ronaldinho okay Akash I will check the
game game it's a deal I will check the
game Rahul like I've mentioned probably
in
January nitzki really likes prism break
well he is much younger than me so we do
probably have different
taste all right very nice very nice MSB
loses so obviously he was uh yeah he
loses but he still is the tournament
over or are there a couple of games
still being
played yeah we'll just uh wait a few
seconds uh just in case no it does say
the tournament is complete and
everything is everything is uh as it
should
be uh so yeah very nicely done
3,164 players uh in the Multiverse
Christmas Multiverse X Christmas Arena
sponsored by multivers X so again big
thanks for that without them it would
not be possible to organize such an
event so quickly and uh yeah first place
we have Maas blam from Germany 110
points uh as you can see he started very
very strong uh and he played a lot more
games than uh contak and mut Pro I guess
they didn't start at the beginning or
maybe they just uh played
slower uh so you know it's hard to say
uh Contra yako uh
who is that I I know him he's in every
tournament oh Jose Alcantara yeah Jose
Martinez
Alcantara and minl from Vietnam who was
leading the entire event uh finishes in
third place ciso effect I don't know who
who it is probably I'm guessing a top GM
who just made a you know an account uhor
kosev in fifth lovic uh that's uh yeah
I'm pretty sure I knew who that was yeah
it is andrein Dimitri andrein in sixth
ala finishes in seventh uh yeah it was a
fairly close but he couldn't quite close
the gap chess master 2006 uh in E uh
that is okay we don't know who that is
uh jalco or you know a veteran of of
Speed play on on leez in ninth uh you
know he he's always dangerous he he
could easily uh go into the top three
and dar in uh 10th Place then you have
Skyline Inferno 11 then Grand Master
susar 42 manir Manda then chess mood
chess mood who is this chess mood Star
International Master maybe next time uh
sarana you guys said it was toyok
International Master then killer Bishop
Green Knight International Master Edis
Gurell and uh Imran potato uh as the 20
and then and so on and so on oh even
Prague played very interesting but he
probably joined late
yeah he had a he had a very nice streak
very nice streak very nice streak and
then he started losing at at the end
yeah very
interesting yeah so it was a really good
event uh uh a lot of a lot of very
strong players who usually join when I
have such a such a big event and yeah
for next time probably we could try a
one plus zero I don't know
uh I'm I'm guessing the quality of the
games will be somewhat reduced uh and I
don't know what people prefer playing
but yeah we could we could try it I mean
uh since I I I myself prefer playing one
plus zero uh a lot more I would never
like for fun I would never play a
OnePlus One game makes no sense to me
but I thought for a serious uh you know
event with prizes maybe people would
prefer a one plus one you know you reach
an end game you actually have time to
play an end
game uh but yeah uh very very nice
tournament big congratulations to the
winners um msb2 Contra yaku and the mood
Pro uh was a I mean incredibly difficult
tournament to win it's not like you play
one one game where you prepare you play
uh I don't know how many games that is
like 50 games over the course of two
hours and you have to be brilliant in in
all of them to win so yeah uh very
nicely done yeah both are good but uh
yeah probably there's a there's a right
answer here I mean there's no no other
way we'll just have to organize a
OnePlus zero next time and see what uh
you know what people think uh but yeah
once again I really hope you guys
enjoyed it and uh thanks a lot to the
players for for joining in it was a
wonderful event winners will be uh
contacted via myself uh regarding the
distribution of prizes as they will uh
be distributed by the by the multivers
sex team uh we're probably going to
accomplish that over the course of the
next two days maybe even tomorrow but
you know it's uh if not tomorrow then
it's Christmas so who knows probably
over the course of the 3 days uh but uh
last time we we did a tournament like
this they pretty much did it very very
quickly like under 24 hours so there
should be no no problems there should be
dealt with fairly quickly and yeah
really really really thanks to the
Multiverse X team for allowing uh uh me
to organize such a wonderful event with
such a such a gracious uh price fund uh
hopefully we'll be able to do something
next year as well and for next year I
was uh even hoping to create some sort
of um some sort of an event where we
could maybe do uh a one tournament like
this every month uh and then really a
big one at the end of the year I'm just
not sure if I wanted to have prizes
every month or have points accumulated
that will be prized maybe uh in a big
tournament at the end of the year so
something that I will still uh discuss
with them of course but yeah uh it is
what I'm preparing sort of for for next
year uh but we'll see how it goes you
know you never know what will happen in
the world uh if you guys have any
suggestions on that also use hasht
suggestion on any of my videos or send
me an email you know if you if you guys
have experience with something like that
or an interesting idea I would very much
enjoy hearing it but yeah that's the
tournament hope you guys enjoyed it
thank you for for joining in thank you
for you know uh keeping me entertained
and hopefully I kept you entertained and
yeah until next time uh hopefully I will
be able to stream uh sooner but until
then uh yeah see you
soon